[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this is cs50 and this is week
one and by the end of today you will
know how to create programs that look
like this so this of course is binary
this is the only language that machines
ultimately understand but thankfully /
last week there's so many abstractions
and there's so many humans that have
come before us that we don't actually
have to write anything at this level we
can abstract way above it like we did
with scratch already and like we will
starting today with C but does anyone
nonetheless want to take a guess at what
that program when fed to your Mac or PC
actually does anyone recognize anyone
want to hazard a guess it's perhaps the
simplest program you could write it
indeed does when fed to the brain of
your computer so called CPU simply print
that so how do we actually get to that
point well recall where we started this
conversation last time talking about
computer science more generally and
problem solving we propose can be
distilled really is this like you've got
some inputs you want some outputs and
somewhere in the middle you need to do
something with those inputs and to get
to that point though we had to represent
those inputs and outputs we just had to
decide as sort of humans how are we
gonna represent all the inputs to our
problem when it comes time to have a
computer actually process them and at
the end of the day all of the phones and
the computers that we're all using only
end at the end of the day plug into the
wall to get their physical resource
electricity and they might store that
temporarily in a battery but that really
is our only input it's either plugged in
or it's not it's either a 1 or a 0 true
or false so the world really reduces to
those two states so to speak and so you
can think of those states then that's
just being like a light bulb on or off
or I pulled up my cell phone last time
to turn the flashlight on or off 1 or 0
true or false
now of course if you only have one light
bulb you can only count from 0 to 1 but
if you start to have a bunch of them
back to back to back to back
you can permute permute them like I did
my fingers 0 1 2 3 and so forth and so
we started talking about binary more
generally and so here for instance
were three sequences of zeros and ones
and each of those represented something
but we don't need to think about the
world at that level we can abstract on
top of that all of us are so much more
familiar with decimal of course and
indeed recall that this was just 72 73
and 33 which if anyone recalls when you
use ASCII which is this global standard
for mapping numbers to letters we got
what message yeah it was just high
capital H capital I exclamation points
and so that's an abstraction on top of
those otherwise binary numbers but we
don't have to model just text using
numbers at the end of the day our only
resource is still that electricity and
the only way we think about it digitally
is still zeros and ones but if we take
these same values 72 73 33 and treat
them in the context of like Photoshop or
like a photo program or a graphics
program we can instead interpret them as
like some amount of red some amount of
green some amount of blue which gave us
last time recall this yellowish color so
now we had another abstraction on top of
binary colors and this is just one pixel
what can you do once you have more than
one pixel what can you represent next
Yeah right images right so we're sort of
continuing the conversation up and up
and up and we could represent something
like a graphical emoji on the screen
which has more than just one yellow dot
it's got a whole bunch of yellow dots
and other colors as well and recall that
if we want to animate things whether
it's through silly things like an emojis
on a phone or just more proper videos in
movies well those are just sequences of
images flying past your human eyes
really quite quickly so that's where we
kind of left off last time starting at
the base level and abstracting away so
that we could sort of stipulate
thereafter we can represent inputs and
we can represent outputs whatever those
happen to be and here on out we don't
need to think at that level we can just
assume we all know how to do this and
even if it eventually becomes kind of a
distant memory we know that someone can
indeed do this and that's the value of
abstraction but inside of this black box
we're so called algorithms the sort of
secret sauce these are this is where the
problems are actually solved and we not
only talked about what these algorithms
are but for instance how efficient they
were so recall that this red line
represented a very simple algorithm just
turning the phone book page by page one
at a time and the reason that it's a
straight line is because there's like a
one-to-one correspondence between how
many page
there are in the book and how many page
turns there are one page one more page
one more turn and so forth if I fly
through it at twice the speed two four
six eight I can do better and so that
yellow line now recall was lower on the
graph if you just kind of look at any
two points yellow in red yellow is below
red saying it takes less time but it was
not quite correct
there was one bug when I was looking for
Mike two pages at a time what was that
issue yeah I might miss him he might
accidentally get sandwiched in between
two pages not a huge deal because I
could fix it but I have to fix it I have
to apply that additional logic and
double back at least a page if I go too
fast but of course the the sort of final
algorithm and frankly all of our initial
intuition probably was the dividing and
conquer up in it roughly to the middle
look down and then go left and go right
and just repeat that process as the
problem gets this big to this big to
this big to this big to just one page
left so that was all about efficiency
but to get to that point we needed to
express ourselves more precisely and so
we introduced pseudocode there's no
formal definition it can be English
English like it's just meant to be
succinct and get the point across and
recall that along the way we introduced
a whole bunch of concepts many of which
you probably experimented with with
scratch like loops and conditions
boolean expressions variables and and so
forth and those were building blocks
that kind of came out of this kind of
demonstration here but honestly even in
this demonstration in this pseudocode
there were a whole bunch of assumptions
right if you read these instructions one
at a time and you're holding the phone
book yourself odds are you can execute
the pseudocode this algorithm but what
does it really mean to say open to the
middle of the phone book all of us have
an intuitive understanding of what that
means but honestly if you were sort of
explaining that to a kid or someone
who's learning English or whatever
language for the first time open to the
middle of the phone book you should
probably set forth some assumptions okay
this thing in front of you has a
thousand pages pieces of paper turn to
the 500th page and let's call that the
middle right this would very get very
quickly get tedious if all of us humans
are talking at that level of detail and
so we abstract away with more sweeping
statements like open to the middle of
the phone book but that's an abstraction
and it's not quite as precise as is
probably ideal especially feeding this
algorithm to a new being or to
robot or computer but it's useful
because we can make a 12 step program
instead of a 20 step program by
elaborating too much and for instance
throughout here - we had our loops and
conditions and so forth but even call
Mike like what does that mean well if
you imagine that the human knows how to
use the phone then it goes without
saying but if he or she also needs to be
programmed to use the phone you've got
to explain you know pick it up hit this
button type this sequence of buttons and
so forth so call Mike is also an
abstraction so these abstractions are
useful but they can sometimes get in the
way especially if you're not precise
enough to program the computer correctly
and to sort of paint this picture
thought we've to begin a little
lightheartedly here brought some some
breakfast if you didn't quite make it
next door beyond just need a couple
volunteers your company appearing on
stage and and on the internet here let
me kind of there's a lot of lights here
how about over there on the left and
over here in the front yeah right there
I think your hand was up come on down
and up Brian do you mind lending us a
hand here - come on down thank you if
you want to take control here let me go
ahead and switch over to another program
for you ok what's your name gene David
nice to meet you have a seat on the on
the far left in your name Abby nice to
meet you as well and the far right if
you could so gene and Abby do you want
to say a little something about
yourselves quickly I mean um
Massachusetts native and I'm taking two
yes for the first time it's my first
time coding or anything so I'm doing
this I know enjoy nice it's glad to have
you with us hi I'm Abby I'm taking this
as a sophomore and I know nothing about
computers or computer science so I'm
probably taking it sad I'm sad okay well
nice to have you as well alright so in
front of us is a whole bunch of
ingredients and hopefully we can kind of
start the semester off gently and if
we're successful we'll actually have a
quick bite here
but we thought we'd defer to the
audience here and Brian's gonna scribe
as we go and all we want to do this
morning just make a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich one instruction at a time
and each of us will just execute what we
hear how's that sounds all right if
someone could volunteer with the first
instruction and Brian will type it down
open bread we heard open bread is the
first instruction so if you deed should
like to execute open bread don't look at
me okay alright so we're kind of on our
way okay I think Abby did it better
certainly but we did it correctly
arguably so let's move on to step two
and see if we can't improve take out
bread okay welcome to the team now nice
all right step three
yeah place two pieces of bread on the
table
never mind the plates okay step four
twist cover of jelly till it opens thank
you
Step five
Step five yeah thank you place the lid
to the side I took some liberties myself
steps take the knife
peel off the cover of the jelly no
covers on ours stick knife into the vids
to the bottle from the top stick ok step
9
rotate hands so jelly ends up on ok
ok step quickly 10
yes step 10
pull out knife
ok step 11
jelly side down on bread
alright step step 12 step 12 anyone yes
thank you
step 13 pour jelly on bread pour jelly
jelly all of it okay now you're just
messing with us
step step 14 put jelly down thank you
15 pick up peanutbutter take lid off
thank you
peel off lid thank you step 18 pick up
knife
bye blunt end scoop okay scoop step 20
put pink put peanut butter on bread 21
21 move up move the knife left to right
please left to right okay step 22 thank
you
23 24 what was that
eat sandwich okay I think we're okay
well how about why don't we each take a
bite and a round of applause if we could
for our volunteers thank you you can
take some fur for the row if you'd like
thank you so thank you Brian okay now I
need a minute sure
thank you so suffice it to say this this
obviously demonstrated even more so than
the the phone book example where are
certain assumptions are and are our
abstractions are and honestly almost all
the time those are useful and of course
we kind of ham things up and I think the
instructions we're kind of helping with
that here but when it comes time to
program with scratch and certainly with
see starting this week you can't really
make as many of those assumptions
anymore because if you don't handle
these sort of corner cases and if you
don't think about what that instruction
means you're going to get the proverbial
spinning beach ball or the hourglass
that you're familiar with on your Mac or
PC the program's gonna crash something's
gonna go wrong just because you missed
some specificity or precision no we're
so happy nutbar so over time we're gonna
find that much like in scratch we were
able to make our own building blocks you
might recall the short examples we did
with the COFF example where I had coffee
row and then caught one and coughed to
where I was making my own puzzle piece
within scratch that was useful because
after that example theoretically I never
again need to think about or worry about
how to implement coffee I can just use
that abstraction but someone has to
implement them and sometimes it's gonna
be other people who come before us and
sometimes it's going to be us so this
isn't to say that programming ends up
being so tedious that you have to point
out every little thing but you or
someone does have to do that level of
precision at least once and nicely
enough in scratch MIT did most of that
legwork for you we all had the building
blocks with which to make our own
animation or game or artwork or the like
but even then you probably had to
connect several dozen puzzle pieces or
even more to get those fundamentals to
do what it is that you wanted it to do
so today we're going to start to
transition from scratch this graphical
programming language that while targeted
at younger students is typically
representative
of a lot of the same concepts that are
now going to label ace throughout the
semester but we're gonna introduce today
an older a more traditional language
that's just text-based and as such it's
a lot more powerful but at first glance
it's actually gonna look a lot more
cryptic in fact instead of writing
zeroes and ones starting today we're
instead gonna write something like this
now if you've never programmed before
odds are at first glance this does look
pretty cryptic and there's a lot of
symbols within a punctuation from the
keyboard there's probably some familiar
English like words and frankly even
after doing scratch anyone even with no
prior background can probably hazard a
guess as to what this program written in
this other language called C does when
you run it it just prints hello world
now granted there's a decent amount of
overhead syntactically there's a bunch
of stuff you have to type to make this
program do what you want it to do but at
the end of the day that's all it's going
to do and this is among the simplest of
programs we're gonna add to our puzzle
pieces so to speak today in see some of
those same concepts that we saw last
time as well so let's do this first
though let me take the take a moment to
sort of compare scratch to see because
the most important takeaway for today is
going to be that even if the syntax
doesn't look so obvious and frankly even
if your first minutes or hours with
writing your own code in C is
frustrating because dammit like you left
off a semicolon or oh I had a
parenthesis in the wrong place there's a
lot of these stupid syntactic hang-ups
that make you feel quite often that you
really aren't getting it but that's not
the important stuff a lot of the syntax
is the least important that's not at all
fundamentally intellectually interesting
so try to see past that and try to take
comfort in the fact that it's the
principles that are gonna be important
and honestly just through muscle memory
and practice all of the other stuff that
at first is going to be an occasional
frustration it just starts to go away as
you start to see this for what it is and
not for the syntax alone that you see on
first glance so this is to say this
program on the right in C is equivalent
to what we did just a week ago with two
puzzle pieces in scratch now there isn't
going to be a green flag on my Mac or my
PC as we move forward that you can just
click we're gonna have to run these
programs in a little different way but
that's all the code on the right is
doing it's equivalent to the code on the
left so let's do this again and again
for just a few of those concepts from
last time and then we'll start writing
some of our own program
so this was an example this purple block
of what concept in programming yeah a
function so it was a verb it was an
action and we're gonna call those
generally functions they just have
functionality built into them so how do
we do this in C well you might remember
from just a moment ago because one of
the lines of code was representative of
this it had some some of this syntax so
in fact if I were to translate the block
on the left hand scratch to the
equivalent code in this other text-based
language called C I'm going to start by
writing print and then open parenthesis
and then close parenthesis and those
parentheses kind of represent the oval
the white oval on the left that we typed
hello world into before now in C it's
not quite as literal as that the
function or the verb is actually not
called print it's called print F and the
F stands for formatted and it just means
that in C you can actually format your
text in different ways so we'll see that
before long and it turns out that you
don't just write hello world between
those parentheses like we did in scratch
you also actually have to surround them
with double quotes in C okay I'm not
such a big deal but something you didn't
have to do before but you know what in C
you're also gonna generally want to be
super specific to the computer and when
you want the cursor the text on the
screen to move down to the next line you
need to tell the computer that by
literally typing backslash n the human
is not going to see a backslash and an N
he or she is actually gonna see the
cursor move to the next line of the
screen like you know like in Google Docs
or in Microsoft Word of like but this
just speaks to the precision that you
need to have when talking to a computer
at this level and not just with the
puzzle pieces and then one last thing
and I alluded to it earlier because it's
sort of the bane of a lot of programmers
early on most lines of code in C have to
end in a semicolon that's the sort of
code equivalent of a period in an
English or some other languages sentence
so that's it it took us a little while
to kind of build that up but that's all
it is the idea on the left of saying
something is the same in C as printing
something with this function called
printf and before I forge ahead with
some other comparisons any questions on
just this translation how do you write
backslash n good so thinking ahead this
would seem to make it hard to literally
show the user backslash n well turns out
that this backslash because it's not a
terribly common character the
programming world uses it
that's what's called an escape character
it's one that you use when you want to
escape information and show it in a
slightly different way so the way you
would show literally to the human a
actual backslash n is to actually in
your code do backslash backslash n
because the second backslash is like
saying treat the next character special
and actually show it to the human and
there's other such examples of that so
how about this one
this orange block was an example of what
concept in scratch yeah so this was a
variable like an x and y and algebra
this is just a placeholder for data and
you could store numbers it turns out you
can store words you can store other
things too in other languages so in C
we're gonna do this we're gonna say
literally the name of the variable we
want for instance counter but we could
call it anything we want equals zero if
we're setting it initially equal to zero
but seeing is a little more pedantic
you've also got to tell the computer
this type of variable I want is
specifically for an integer otherwise
abbreviated int so you have to tell the
computer in advance what type of data
you're gonna store in it and take a
guess you got to finish the thought and
see what's what more do we need to add
to the yep just a semicolon and that's
it it looks a little more cryptic but
the idea is fundamentally the same so
what if we wanted to do this in scratch
change counter by one this was
equivalent to incrementing or adding one
to counter well let me go ahead and
propose that you could literally just do
this in C set counter equal to whatever
counter currently is plus one that seems
to be kind of the right intuition and
now notice what's key to note here is
that this equal sign isn't saying that
counter equals counter plus one because
that just doesn't seem possible right if
you pick any value for counter like the
number one well one definitely does not
equal 1 plus 1 which is 2 and 1 does not
equal 2 and you can come up with an
infinite number of worrisome incorrect
comparisons so the equal sign in C like
a lot of languages we'll see in the
class actually means assignment copy the
value on the right into the value on the
left so set counter equal to whatever it
is plus 1 what we got to finish the
thought so we need a semicolon
I don't though need to ream ention int
and why might that be
yeah I already told the computer it's an
integer you don't need to repeat
yourself by mentioning int again
assuming in this context even though
we're looking at it just on the slide
has actually been created before just
like you did with scratch by saying make
a variable so it turns out you can be a
little more succinct in C in a lot of
languages if you find this a little
tedious to type and you know it's a
little verbose it's a bunch of
keystrokes you can actually abbreviate
it with just this
so plus equals is just syntactic sugar
as a programmer would say it's just a
nice fancy feature that lets you write
fewer words or characters but do the
same thing and frankly we can do a
little better and if you take in APCs
you might have seen this in Java as well
you can also simplify this even more to
just counter plus plus semicolon so
that's it all equivalent this is just a
little more efficient and as you get
more comfortable programming saving
keystrokes just saves you time now this
of course was an example of what in
scratch by contrast yeah we called this
a condition and it had a boolean
expression that we were asking a
question of in this case where
apparently asking in scratch is X less
than Y and if so say it on the screen so
how might we translate this to C well
turns out we can quite simply translate
this one pretty literally we've seen
almost all of the building blocks thus
far but we do have to introduce a little
something new here notice that the
printf line is almost identical to what
I used earlier for just hello world I've
obviously just changed the the words in
it but I still have the backslash n I
still have the quotes still have the
semicolon so that the rest of that is
the same now if is new but this is a one
to one translation scratch calls that if
C calls it if and the only additional
thing you need in C is parentheses
around the boolean expression so that's
what takes the place of the little green
block there and then assuming x and y
are indeed variables that we created
earlier you can just compare them like
this and you can use greater than and
other symbols for comparison as well but
there is something a little interesting
and most of us don't often have occasion
to even use these keys on our keyboard
curly braces on a u.s. keyboard they
tend to be over on the top right above
your Enter key these are just kind of
C's equivalent of this shape notice that
all of the yellow most of the yellow
blocks in scratch kind of had this like
embracing or this embracing shape to
them you can simulate that in C by
having what's called an open curly brace
a close curly brace so that's the same
exact idea now as an aside you don't
technically always need these curly
braces if you've just got a one-liner
like this you can omit them as you might
see online or in text books but we'll
just always draw them for consistency so
that the C code always looks like this
what if you wanted to express this
though if X is less than Y then say X is
less than Y else say X is not less than
Y well turns out this is almost
identical the first four lines perfectly
the same as before but it turns out and
so you can literally say else after that
closing curly brace and then just print
out alternatively whatever is you want
to say so this is like the fork in the
road if you go one way say this you go
the other way say this other thing any
questions on these comparisons thus far
yeah a really good question do you put
can you or do you put the curly brace on
the same line as the if you can and
we're gonna talk about this in the next
couple of weeks this matter of style
there are different ways I could express
this exact same code frankly I could
write out all of this code with no
spaces whatsoever in fact just to make
that point if I go ahead and just open
up a simple text editor here not to
actually program but to just type
something I could actually do something
like this if X less than Y then go ahead
and print out X is less than Y backslash
n semicolon curly brace else print and
so forth
completely unreadable at the end of the
day or unmaintainable especially when
the code gets complicated but whitespace
does not tend to matter to the computer
but it does matter to the human and as
you're alluding to in some languages
it's actually conventional to do this
where you actually keep the curly brace
on the same line and indeed you might
see textbooks do this as well some
people will even do this these are all
long story short matters of style in
cs50 in the earliest weeks of the class
we're going to insist that everyone
follow the same style so that we have
some basis for comparison but it
eventually this is the kind of thing
that like in your own English writing or
whatever language you tend to write and
you have your own sort of stylistic or
linguistic flair to it
code has that
as well other questions yeah really good
question when you declare a variable
create a variable do you have to set it
something to equal to something right
away short answer no and we'll see
examples of that before long where you
can actually say give me a give me a
variable called counter but don't
actually set it equal to some value come
back to that in a bit all right so what
if we want to add this logic frankly and
scratch it's starting to look a little
overwhelming but this is just a 3-way
fork in the road if X is less than Y say
so else if X is greater than Y say so
else if x equals y then go ahead and say
they're equal and in C we can do this
translation pretty directly as well in
fact now the first eight lines of code
are identical to before except this
middle one here where I'm adding a
second boolean expression is X greater
than Y and then I have this third
condition else if x equals y but there
seems to be a typo perhaps or something
anomalous here does anything jump out
yeah yeah you have a double equal sign
which maybe is just a typographical
error on my part but turns out it's not
this is deliberate but why this seems
like our first example of where'd
scratch doesn't really matter fect li to
see yeah exactly we already a moment ago
decided as humans really years ago
equals is actually in the context of si
going to be assignment copy the value
from the write to the value on the left
and so we kind of painted ourselves into
a corner we still as humans as
programmers want to be able to express
the notion of equality and comparing but
if we've already used the equal sign for
assignment we need another pattern of
symbols to represent equality and as it
turns out humans just chose two equal
signs instead so slightly different from
scratch the recent scratch does it this
way is because you don't really want to
have to get into those weeds certainly
when the target audience is you know
eight-year-olds just learning to program
in the first place it's not important
nor is it really important for us but
for us there's going to be a logical
distance because if we use the wrong one
behaviors gonna be wrong if we had just
one equal sign we would literally be
changing X to equal Y rather than just
comparing it how was their hand in here
yeah good question if you wanted to
express greater than or equal to how
might you do that it turns out there are
ways to do that and if I go ahead and
just give myself some place to draw here
for a moment you can actually indeed do
less than or equal or greater than or
equal there's no way on a typical
keyboard to put them atop each other
like you might recall from math class so
you just put them next to each other the
well it depends I want the equals the
double equal sign here because I want to
explicitly check this third case and say
X is equal to Y so that was my goal but
luckily this is not necessary right like
to make the program a little better
designed how many possible cases are
there when comparing two integers x and
y for greater than less than or equality
well can I just answer the question
tonight is there a 3x excellent there's
three scenarios there X is either less
than or greater than or equal to and I'm
hard-pressed to think of a fourth so do
I need this amount of specificity what
could I do to give myself a slight
optimization improve the code just a
little bit just to save myself a little
bit of time writing it and maybe even
the computer a little time running it
yeah yeah I don't need the last
condition because if we all agree
logically that either X is less than Y
or greater than Y or maybe equal to Y
well if there's only a third and final
case that can just be my so-called else
just make that be the so-called default
case and in fact even though this is
what most people would call an over
optimization you are saving the computer
some time because suppose that X does in
fact equal Y then they're both the value
number one so is one less than one when
this line of code is executed true or
plug yes or no like no obviously not one
is not less than one so this code does
not execute but the boolean expression
is evaluated so to speak the question is
asked is one greater than one
no and so this code is not executed but
this
boolean expression is so we just spent
another step or second or whatever
however fast the computer is is one
equal to one yeah it is so this actually
prints but to your point you don't need
to ask that question and in fact you
just increase by a factor of 50% how
many questions you're asking so you just
wasted a little bit of time now as an
aside are Macs and PCs and phones these
days I mean again they're operating it
like a gigahertz speed 1 billion things
per second so in practice who cares if
you're asking that third question and
frankly if it makes your code more
readable or to your Teaching Fellow or
to a colleague or a friend who's working
on the program for you then that's great
if it's more clear from the code what's
going on leave it that way but these are
the kinds of design decisions that we'll
know I make and arguably this version of
the scratch program and this version of
the C code is just a little better
design because right why write more code
than you need to to express the exact
same idea all right
so what about this this was a loop in
scratch this was an infinite loop
because it was just forever saying hello
world now in C this gets a little less
directly translated it turns out C uses
the key word while so there is no
forever keyword in C but there is the
word while and of course I'm gonna use
my curly braces B or curly braces curly
brackets to kind of encompass the
following lines of code the line of code
I want in there it's just another printf
so that's the exact same as before but
it's not sufficient to just say while it
turns out that while wants you to ask it
a question every time the loop executes
and it's gonna check that question and
if the answer is yes it's going to run
the loop but if the answer being asked
in C is ever no or false it's going to
not execute the code and it's just going
to move on to any further lines of code
lower down in the file so in C you
actually need a pair of parentheses
after the keyword while and then you
need to ask a question you need to ask a
question like is X less than Y or a
question like is X greater than Y or is
X equal to Y but none of those scenarios
apply because the whole purpose of this
scratch block is literally to do
something forever so what's a question
we could ask to which the answer is
surely true does one equal one we could
kind of contrive an arbitrary but very
mathematically correct sin air
we could just say does 1 equal equal 1
but it turns out you can be even more
succinct because in C there's a couple
key words one of which is true one of
which is false and the word true is by
definition always true and the word
false is by definition always false so
you don't need to contrive some
arbitrary but correct idea of like does
1 equal equal 1 or does 50 equal equal
50 you don't need to just come up with
some arbitrary solution you can
literally just say true because that
keyword true never changes value so even
though this is a little weird looking
it's how you induce something to happen
forever you ask the same question again
and assume that the question is always
has the same answer of true any
questions on that one yeah and back good
question do spaces matter short answer
no not in this case you can add in fact
the lead all of the spaces here except
for the one in the English phrase and it
would still be functionally correct you
can even add spaces anywhere you want
you can make this taller by hitting
Enter a bunch of times tab spaces around
the word true all of the examples also
here today and you'll see in the coming
weeks are sort of the better way to do
things because they're more readable but
again as you get more comfortable with
code or if you're coming in with some
prior experience you might already have
your own opinions and frankly this is
just a religious debate among
programmers which is the right way to
write your code and that's fine once you
get comfy so long as you're consistent
is the most important thing you don't
need to adhere to one person's or the
other so how does this code work
logically well the first thing the
computer your Mac or PC or your phone or
whatever is going to do it's going to
ask the question well true well true is
always true so it's going to proceed to
execute the line of code but after it
does because that's the entirety of the
code that's in between the curly braces
we could have more lines these are just
short programs the computer is going to
check ok is true still true yes so it's
going to execute it again then it's
gonna ask the question again is true
still true yes so it's gonna execute the
code again and this is going to repeat
literally forever but what if you don't
want to repeat something forever what if
you only want to repeat it 50 times
scratch doesn't make you think very hard
about this it will just figure out how
to keep track of 1 2 3 4 5 and all the
way up to 50 and then stop that's nice
it makes it easy to use the
see and a lot of languages aren't quite
that user-friendly you will see later in
the semester that newer languages are a
little closer to what scratch offers but
in C we need to be more explicit but
this is a chance to use some of these
more primitive building blocks in C the
equivalent of repeat is going to be the
preposition for just because for now and
then just as before if we want to do
something again and again within this
loop we're gonna use the curly braces
similar to the little orange block there
and then what am I gonna do I'm gonna do
this every time 50 times hopefully print
out hello world so now I just need to
figure out and see how to express the
number of times specifically 50 so it
turns out in C you use parentheses again
this is gonna be a pretty common
characteristic of a lot of the function
of the code rewrite and then you need to
do three things the burden is now going
to be on us the programmer to keep track
of how many times we want to execute
this code - how many times we've already
executed this code and then constantly
make sure that one does not exceed the
other so we stop once we hit 50 so
what's the sort of fundamental contract
that we use to keep track of anything in
a program a counter which was an example
of a variable so we just need to use a
variable now it's actually going to be
inside of the parenthesis this time so
it's not on its own as it was just a bit
ago but the syntax is the same I could
call it counter but the reality is it
the convention in programming is just to
use shorter variables when you're just
doing something mundane and if all
you're doing is looping I stands for
integer is sort of many programmers go
to variable name rather than the more
verbose but correct counter or whatever
so this says hey computer give me a
variable called I let me store integers
or int in it and set the initial value
to zero why well almost everyone in this
room probably starts counting from one
computers just tend to car start
counting from zero but why what's the
rationale for starting to count from
zero perhaps based on last week why is
that kind of makes sense see what do you
think
yeah it's it's just ones and zeroes and
like what's the smallest number negative
values decide that you can represent in
binary well it's just zero zero zero a
bunch of zeros so why would you waste
that representation that permutation of
bits let's just start counting at zero
and then add to that so you can start
counting from one in safe but the
convention in most languages is count
from zero so we'll get off on that foot
as well and you might recall even that
in our PBJ code for the peanut butter
and jelly snout enough for the PBJ code
for the for the phone book pseudocode i
actually deliberately started numbering
the lines from zero to one to two for
that same intuition so here's how you
then say to the computer check if you
would whether i is less than 50 now
initially it's obviously gonna be less
than 50 because 0 is less than 50 but
that same condition is going to be
checked again and again and again as
this loop executes and then recall from
before we can just plus plus a variable
to add one to it we could do this for a
more more verbose lis we could say I
equals I plus 1 but it's just more
conventional to write I plus plus just
to say the same thing more tersely
so what happens next logically that's
the code I've written what does the
computer do with it well it initializes
I to 0 and prepares to store integers in
it it checks the condition just in case
you initialized it to too big of a value
you might not want the loop to execute
at all but obviously 0 is less than 50
so this line of code executes take a
guess as to what happens next
yeah you probably want to do I plus plus
because you've done executing all the
lines of code in between the curly
braces even though there's just one so
let's go ahead and increment I so I is
now 1 let's now make sure is 1 less than
50 obviously execute the code I plus
plus is 2 less than 50 obviously execute
the code I plus plus is 3 less than 50
obviously now go ahead and execute the
code and again and again and again and
at some point we're gonna get up to I
equals 49 and is 49 less than 50
obviously so we print out hello world
and then I plus plus kicks in and then
it's is 50 less than 50 no
so wait that feels like a logical error
though no should I be checking if I is
less than or equal to 50
yeah because if I started from zero I
already spent that one additional cycle
so I can count from zero through 49
which seems to work or from one through
fifty but the convention in programming
honestly is typically to start counting
at some value and then count up to but
not through some value just because but
logically you can implement this in half
a dozen different ways most likely all
right let's look at one final example
that allowed us to actually get user
input in scratch recall that we use this
block to actually get the name of
someone in lecture and we also in the
animation with the gingerbread house
used it to get yes or no do you want the
cupcake or the apple or the like so this
is an example of a function in scratch
that actually takes input like the
sentence what's your name but it also
returns a value which in this case was
just hard coded in scratch by MIT to be
called answer so it's like a special
variable called answer but effectively
it's being handed back to the user so
how might we think about this in C it
turns out that you can express this line
of code a little more for Bhosle than
before by using a new function called
getstring so get underscore string is
the name of the function the underscore
is convention in C if you ever want to
have a space you can't have spaces in
the names of functions so people just
started using underscores like you might
in your own like social media user names
and the like is the convention there as
well here's the sentence I want to
display and I'm gonna start calling this
more formally a string a string in a
programming language is just a sequence
of characters like it's a word it's a
phrase it's a character it's a paragraph
this is a string anything between double
quotes is a string in C and the
backslash n is just end of line as
before we still already have the
semicolon but this isn't quite a literal
translation of what's going on just yet
because I also now need to do something
with the answer
so if getstring is a function that
actually gets input from the user as via
his or her keyboard just like the blue
block in scratch in c we need to be a
little more explicit as to where we're
putting the return value from that
function what it is it's handing back
and so I can store it in a variable
called answer I could call it anything I
want but for consistency with scratch
let's call it answer but recall what
what we
have to do in see anytime we create a
variable we have to be more precise yeah
we have to define it so let me call it
type or class if you took in taking a
previous class its type and it's not
going to be an int because probably the
words being typed in or not numbers it's
gonna be this time what I just call it a
string and so indeed we would declare
the variable on the left by saying give
me a string call it answer and assign to
it whatever's on the right well what's
on the right what is on the right is
whatever this function gets string comes
back with and gets stored from right to
left so how do I now say this person's
name well in scratch I just say say and
then I drag and drop the answer variable
end is done what's the function in C
with which we can say something though
on the screen yeah so printf print a
formatted string even though we haven't
really seen any formatting yet until now
it turns out in C you have to actually
tell printf if you're not passing in a
hard-coded string or sentence you have
to pass the printf which called a format
code or a format string this first input
to printf now printf apparently seems to
take two things the first is this one
before the comma the second is the thing
after the common we've not seen this
before yet in C so printf is being told
go ahead and print out a string that
looks like this person s is a
placeholder and S stands for string and
that literally is a placeholder saying
printf I'm gonna give you a string to
plug in to this first input what is that
string literally the answer variable now
it feels like we're jumping through
hoops here right it would have been nice
to just say printf open parenthesis
answer closed parenthesis semicolon and
be done with it that's just not the way
printf works in older versions you could
maybe do something a little more simple
like that but honestly we're not
typically going to be printing out just
what the human typed in after all this
is kind of a stupid example at the
moment I'm typing in a word you're just
saying it on the screen we already
decided in scratch that's kind of lame
it'd be nice to at least have the
program not just say David or whatever
the name is but what did we do last time
like hello comma David but this would
seem to give us that capability right
right now I'm literally
printing out the human's name in C but
let me change this ever so slightly just
as we did in scratch recall that in C we
did this green block of join where I
literally get past join two arguments
the first one was hello comma space the
second one was answer and this
concatenated this combined back-to-back
those two strings well in C thanks to
printf we can do that same thing it's
just a different syntax printf still
gets one argument first that is the
string you want to format ergo the F in
printf but this time I'm gonna literally
say h-e-l-l-o comma space % s4 string
and then give prints up a second
argument which is it's instruction to go
ahead and plug in whatever this variable
is to whatever this placeholder is and
so here we've now joined the two strings
effectively and thus was born a our
first formatted string any questions
then on that yeah what if you want to
say something extra after you could
certainly continue the logic like you
don't have to end this quoted expression
with % s you could say hello comma % s
comma nice to meet you and then what
printf will do is it's only going to
substitute that variable called answer
where the % s is and if you want to have
2% s is you could just add another comma
here and pass in another variable in a
third variable and even more thus
formatting the string even more detailed
question over here other questions yeah
I'm back how do you make a distinction
between the placeholders if you have
different variables it's the ordering
from left to right so in this case it's
a trivial example because there's only
one variable and one placeholder but if
as you were hinting I had multiple % s
something something something % s
something something something I would
just make sure that I pass printf the
first variable comma the second variable
comma the third variable and so forth
left to right other questions yeah
because I screwed up and didn't include
that and I was gonna fix it after class
quickly bug it's a bug yeah sure
same exact thing comma answer comma
answer with two percent SS if you want
to say the same variable twice in two
places for whatever reason two
placeholders and then answer comma
answer to plug that in twice other quote
yeah no and we're gonna see some others
in just a bit it turns out there's
others it's percent I for integer and
there's going to be even more than that
percent see for a single character and
more other questions yeah good question
if I did have correctly and if this
weren't a PDF I were just edited on the
fly if I didn't have that if I want if I
had the percent and it always has to go
in the formatted string in the first
argument so the only thing that comes
after printf spher star Gyun is
optionally argued a variable comma
variable come a variable comma variable
other questions alright so let's go
ahead and actually do something with
code I'm gonna go ahead and open up
another window and this is a tool called
cs50 sandbox and this is a tool will via
the web via which you can actually play
with code and I'll show in just a moment
how I get to this particular location
but let me first explain the user
interface much like we started off our
conversation with scratch so I need a
place to write code the reality is I
could just use my own Mac I could just
use my own PC frankly I could even use
certain mobile devices these days but
then we would have hundreds of other
people in the class all with slightly
different configurations on their Macs
and their PCs and their phones and the
like and so everyone would kind of had
different software and different
settings and that just never works very
well so at the beginning of the course
we just standardized everything by
actually using a web-based environment
just like scratches whereby we'll all
have access to the exact same computer
but virtualized in the so-called cloud
if you've ever wondered what the cloud
is
it just means other people's servers
somewhere on the internet that people
can use for free or to rent and now I
have to host those physical servers
themselves so cs50 sandbox just like
scratch is a cloud-based application
that someone else wrote that's hosted on
the Internet and the user interface at
first glance looks just like this there
are only two components to it at the top
of the user interface of cs50 sandbox is
just a code editor a very simple text
editor similar in spirit to Google Docs
and Microsoft Word and so forth but much
simpler there's no formatting there's no
bold facing and centering you can just
type words of text down here is the
so-called terminal window but we'll come
back to that in just a moment let me go
ahead and write my first program let me
go ahead and write include standard i/o
dot H int main void open curly brace
printf hello world backslash n semicolon
done
okay now know few people in this room
could probably whip up a parent program
that quickly unless you do have prior
background and if you did take APCs or
something else looks kind of like Java
but not quite the same but this is my
first program now recall from earlier
this was the black and white program we
saw on the slide just a little bit ago
and even if you didn't quite appreciate
what all the funky syntax is doing all
of us probably had the intuition of what
this program does which is just to print
out the words at the end of the day
hello world and we'll tease apart in
just a bit what all these various lines
are doing but the interesting part is
what's highlighted in green here and
this is just one of the features of cs50
sandbox it will color code different
concepts within your code so that they
just kind of jump out at you the colors
aren't actually there you don't have to
color code things yourself it just does
it automatically so that you can see the
different components just like MIT color
eise's the various scratch puzzle piece
is the same so this is a program called
that I want to call hello it's in a file
this is just a tab up top called hello.c
because it turns out when you write a
program in C you save it in files by
human convention whatever dot C as the
file extension so to speak how do I like
run this program right there's no green
flag to click which which scratch gave
us so how do I actually run the program
and you know frankly moreover the green
flag seems to be the
least of my concerns what is the
language that any computer understands
whether it's my Mac here or the cloud
server where this thing is zeros and
ones right and we started with that sort
of overwhelming slide of the lots of
zeros and ones and that is where the
point we need to get to but hopefully we
ourselves don't have to write at that
level of tedium so we need some way of
converting this code from C which will
start calling source code which is the
English like code we see on the screen
that's mildly pleasurable to write as
opposed to just zeros and ones but we
nonetheless need to convert it somehow
to zeros and ones and so the way we can
do this is essentially as follows if we
have what we'll start calling our source
code which can be written in our case in
C but you can write source code in Java
and C++ and Python and dozens of other
language source codes a generic term
that just means the code that we humans
have written we need some way of
converting it into zeros and ones which
henceforth we're just gonna call machine
code which feels like a reasonable name
it's the zeros and ones that a machine
understands how does the machine know
what zeros and ones to understand well
that's the whole reasoning behind having
CPU central processing units the brains
of a computer they are just hardwired at
the factory so to speak you know with
Intel's factory to understand certain
patterns of zeros and ones but the point
for us now is we need to take source
code like the C program I wrote a moment
ago that's supposed to print hello world
and somehow convert it to machine code
so it turns out this is the step that
humans who've come before us have solved
for us other humans have already written
programs that we're going to start
calling a compiler that allows us to
convert source code to machine code it's
just one additional step this step did
not exist in scratch but we're going to
run a program that's generally called a
compiler that we pass our program to as
input and we get as outputs the machine
code thereby perfectly bringing us full
circle to what computer science is in
now the context of programming input
source code outputs machine code the
algorithm or the special software we're
going to use in just a moment is called
a compiler that just converts one to the
other so that none of us have to ever
think about or write in
Zero's and once so it's a little
old-school how you do this in scratch
you obviously just hit the green flag
and MIT and all those folks took care of
it for you we have to be a little more
manual about this and that's where the
second piece of the cs50 sandbox user
interface comes into play notice I have
a blinking prompt here there's a dollar
sign at left which is just a common
convention a dollar sign tends to in
these types of computers represent a
prompt it's waiting for me to type
something and indeed it's literally
blinking waiting for me to type
something this is an example of a
terminal window and your own Mac and
your own PC actually has or can have
this exact same feature it's just all of
us kind of operate with graphical user
interfaces these days so we've got
buttons and menus and things to drag and
click but back in the day and typically
in programming you don't bother with
these sort of aesthetics you actually
get your hands dirty err with just the
keyboard alone typing anything you want
to do and at first it might feel like a
regression like why are we doing why are
we giving up all these beautiful
amenities of modern computers but it's
more powerful and it's more explicit it
lets you do exactly what you want to do
by sending commands to the computer so
this is my terminal one I can create
others just to have multiple windows but
this is giving me access to the
underlying server that I now have access
to so if any of you when we comes time
to the first problem set log into the
same tool you don't all have the same
environment you all have your own
isolated copies of the same software but
your own storage space so to speak so I
need to somehow convert hello dot C to
zeros and one and the way I'm gonna do
this is like this clang which stands for
C language hello dot C enter and the
fact that I see nothing happening is
actually an amazing thing because
there's an infinite number of things
frankly that can go wrong and the
computer will happily yell at you with
its cryptic looking error messages if
any of those things do go wrong so
seeing nothing but another blinking
prompt with a dollar sign it's actually
a good thing my code has somehow been
converted to zeros and ones where are
those zeros and ones well by convention
they are stored in a file that's weirdly
and historically just called a dot out
and we
see that if I click this folder icon up
here you'll actually see my file hello
dot C and another file now called a dot
out stands for assembly output but for
historical reasons now if I let me close
the folder icon because we're generally
not going to use the graphical user
interface how do I run that program I
couldn't just double click on the icon
this isn't a Mac this isn't a PC this is
a cloud-based Linux environment Linux is
a super popular operating system happens
to be used by lots of computer
scientists lots of websites lots of
servers in fact almost every website you
visit these days is powered if not by
Windows by Linux and variations thereof
called UNIX and other flavors still it's
just a very popular and often free
operating system that cs50 sandbox
itself uses to run a file called a dot
out that's in this folder so to speak
even though you don't see a graphical
version of it you literally just type
dot slash a dot out completely
non-obvious and kind of a stupid name
for the program but this is the
equivalent in your Mac or PC of double
clicking on an icon let me go ahead and
hit enter and when I do I should
hopefully see what hello world and here
we go Wow I think that's our first
program like it's not doing all that
much but it's at least doing what we
promised it would do and this is the
equivalent in scratch of just saying on
the screen hello world now to be fair
there were more steps involved and God
knows there was more cryptic looking
code to write but at the end of the day
all we've done now is reimplemented
we're now going to very quickly
introduce new puzzle pieces but in C but
first let's solve this sort of minor
headache I don't really want to sort of
tell friends like hey everyone like come
run my a dot out program like let's give
it a real name suppose I just want to
call my program hello like you might
download from the App Store or Google
Play Store a programs have names so how
do I do that well it turns out in a
terminal window the so called command
line environment which is just a fancy
way of saying you write lines of
commands with your keyboard you can
actually pass in what are called command
line arguments additional inputs to
programs that are just words that you
type at your keyboard that tell it how
to behave so instead of just running
clang on hello
I'm actually gonna be more explicit and
I'm gonna tell clang please output as is
implied by literally typing - Oh for
output a file called hello instead so
it's a little more verbose hello - oh
hello oh sorry
clang - oh hello hello dot C but what
this is going to do now is still convert
source code to machine code but it's
going to save it in a file called hello
and indeed now I have hello dot C a dot
out and hello as pictured in the little
graphical folder there so now I can
instead run dot slash hello what should
it say hopefully the same enter so
that's it those are called command line
arguments and it's just sort of the
old-school way of telling a text-based
command how to behave a little bit
differently from its defaults but
frankly this is going to get tedious
quickly like we aren't going to want to
write our code and then every darn time
we want to convert it to zeros and ones
to run it actually remember these sort
of magical incantations of commands and
so humans have abstracted these away -
it turns out that if you want to make a
program from source code into machine
code there's another command you can use
and you can literally type make Hello
where Hello is the name of the program
you want to make this program whose name
is make will look for a file by default
called
hello dot C therefore saving you the
time of specifying it hit enter now and
oh my god look what it just did
it has even more configuration options
that are baked into it in week the cs50
staff configured cs50 sandbox to have
these various features and even though
we're not going to go into detail on
them now I'm going to wave my hand at
what they actually do they just make
additional features possible that will
eventually get to but this would be
otherwise the command that you all do
have to type in just to three or three
or four weeks time and no one can ever
remember that I certainly couldn't so
make just automates that for you but
when you run make make is not a compiler
make is not the thing in the middle here
converting source code to machine code
it's just a second program that some
humans wrote years ago that use clang in
an automated way to achieve the same
output because people got tired
typing stuff like this so someone made a
program called make that does it for us
any questions alright let's add a little
bit then to this program instead of this
version of hello let me get some user
input and actually do something with it
suppose I actually want to get the
user's name and then print that out well
we saw the spoiler for that just a
moment ago but let me go ahead and add
it to this program here now I have a
second line of code and I want to get a
string from a user and how do i with
what function do I get a string from the
user
it gets string was the one and recall I
can do get underscore string open
parenthesis and then I have to pass in
an argument so to speak like give me
your name this is actually what do we
say before what is your name I think was
the prompt backslash n semicolon now
it's not enough to just get the string
what do I want to do with it yeah store
it in a variable what type of variable a
string so I just need to go on the left
hand side of this line of code and say
okay well give me a string I'll call it
name but I could call it X or Y or
anything but name feels like a good
descriptor for using a single equal sign
to copy from right to left and now I've
got that now it's not sufficient to just
store the value in the variable I need
to print it out so let me start with
this all right you don't have to it auto
saves the sandbox so I don't even have
to go up to file save or anything let me
go ahead and do make Hello now uh-oh oh
my God look at all these errors already
so clearly something is wrong as the
computer is fond of telling me in red
and frankly this is where you very
quickly get derailed they're kind of
freaked out because oh my god I only
wrote two lines of code how do I have 20
lines of errors somehow so the computer
is kind of as confused as you and the
most important thing when you face this
kind of situation where it's just
cryptic erroneous output start at the
top even if your window is kind of small
and therefore a whole bunch of stuff
Scrolls on the screen quickly scroll up
to the top because odds are there's one
mistake up at the very top and that one
mistake just had a cascading effect on
the computer on the compiler that it
just got really confused and it just
kept spitting out messages because it
got tripped up early so let's scroll
back up to the top here and here's the
very long command that I said make
automates for you
so that's not erroneous here seems to be
the first error and it's a little
cryptic still but let's glean some
information here's a familiar phrase
hello dot C let me go ahead and zoom in
on the bottom here so hello dot C you
recall is the name of my file albeit non
obviously clang is telling me look at
line 5 and then your 5th character so
this something colon something means
line number character or column number
if you're looking from left to right
error means error and then this is where
things get a little sophisticated use of
undeclared identifier string did you
mean standard in now I didn't but I do
recognize standard in or rather it seems
similar to standard i/o but no I didn't
mean that I'm pretty sure this code is
right well why am I getting this error
it sounds like string on line 5 v
character right there that is wrong well
it turns out there is no such thing as a
string C the language has integers and
it has boolean's it turns out and it has
characters and a few other things it
actually doesn't have strings strings is
a word that's useful to describe
sequences of characters paragraphs words
but string is not a type it's not a type
of variable unless you make it so and in
fact this is one of the simplifications
we do in just the first couple of weeks
of the course to get us off the ground
it turns out that we need to add one
line of code here we need to do not only
include standard i/o which we'll explain
in a moment but also cs50 so called
library so cs50 has a lot of humans
involved with it and over time we've
decided you know what we could make like
the first hour of cs50 a little easier
and the sort of on-ramp a little cleaner
for folks with no background by just
inventing a few features ourselves such
as the ability to get strings from the
user so it turns out getstring is also
not a function that comes with C that is
a custom puzzle piece so to speak that
cs50 made and where we created that
function is essentially in a file called
cs50.h and so by including cs50.h you
now get access to more puzzle pieces if
you will that we have created for you
and it turns out this line of code that
has been here before
is also giving you features too
right we're just doing what everyone
does in programming which is solve a
problem once and then let other people
use that solution take a guess what
functionality is actually implemented in
a file called standard i/o input output
dot H this is just a file somewhere on
the server that actually does come with
C and it provides you with handy
features like what say again
Oh what's why printf it turns out that
the means by which you are allowed to
use a function called printf here is you
have to include the file in which it is
declared so some humans years ago
literally wrote a function a puzzle
piece called printf and they figured out
how to actually draw characters on the
screen they then stored information
about that function in a file called
standard IOH if I had not included that
seemingly cryptic line of code at the
very top of my previous program even
that hello world program would not have
worked because clang the compiler
wouldn't have known what I'm talking
about what is printf I don't know what
that is unless you tell it to also
include this file that humans wrote
years ago in which printf has been
created and now if I want to use
getstring as well as the new key word
string I need to tell clang the compiler
also go ahead and look in cs50 dot
H for more functionality such as string
and getstring so let me go ahead now and
try this again I'm gonna clear my
terminal here and just try that same
command again make Hello enter dammit
now I've got another error but but but
progress well no well no just as many
errors as before somehow but different
ones notice now well wait that was
before oh no I'm sorry it is fewer
errors here's where I ran the command a
moment ago and now I'm getting this
error instead ok so progress
now my error is not on line 5 it's on
line 6 though fun fact mine 6 used to be
line 5 so it's apparently still involved
in the problem so let's read the error
message the problem is on line 6 which
not surprising is that one there but
this time it's different error unused
variable name ok that one I kind of
understand even without being a
programmer
what is the what does that mean yeah
maybe declare prior to using but turns
out this is how you declare it but I'm
actually yeah yeah I'm just kind of
wasting the computer's time I'm creating
it so line six on the left is correct
hey computer give me a string variable
and call it name and put a value in it
but what's the point of that exercise if
you're never as you say doing anything
with it and in perfect recall from the
slide a moment ago how do I do something
with it well this is not how you do
something with it if I go ahead and run
this program now successfully what would
I actually see on the screen
like literally hello name h-e-l-l-o
comma space n am E obviously not correct
so how do I plug in the variable what
was the trick yeah percent s for string
a format code so to speak hence the name
printf and then I need to pass a second
argument to printf and I do that with a
comma
and then the name of the variable I want
to plug in now notice there are two two
commas in this line here if i zoom in
notice there's two commas but there's
only two arguments or inputs to printf
the input to a function is just
typically called an argument or also
called a parameter so there's two commas
but this one is in English comma just
separating hello from the the person's
name this white comma here color coded
because the the sandbox is doing that
for me is actually separating excuse me
the first argument from the second
argument so now for a third time make
Hello enter oh my god thank you now it
worked it still spit out this pretty
long cryptic command in white but that's
okay that is again the automated command
that make is making possible for us but
the fact that I see no red no errors
just another blinking prompt means that
my program has been made so let me go
ahead and do how do I run a program if
it's called hello yeah dot slash hello
and we'll see why you have the stupid
dot at the beginning it essentially
means run the program called hello
that's right here in your current folder
on the server dot slash hello what is
your name very nice
David enter hello David
interesting let's make one tweak because
I did this by accident earlier as you
noted
what if I left off for instance one of
these backslash ends that's literally
now not telling the computer to move the
cursor to another line so let me go
ahead and rerun the program wait a
minute that looks the same I just
changed the code but it's still behaving
exactly the same what where's my
confusion yeah I didn't recompile it
right unlike scratch which is amazing
because you just hit the green flag and
it runs the code again we have a second
intermediate step I have to rerun the
code now how do you get out of a program
I could just hit enter you can also hit
ctrl C 4 cancel and that will just get
you out of whatever confusion you're in
let me go ahead and rerun make hello
seems to be ok
dot slash hello enter okay this is why
I've had all those backslash ends let me
zoom in on what's happening I mean it
doesn't look horrible but frankly it
kind of rubs me the wrong way if like
this is what my program looks like when
I'm typing in user input I mean this
just looks stupid right minimally I
should add a space maybe I can put
backslash n to move the character this
should just user interface now this
isn't really logic it's just aesthetics
but I think this looks stupid so that's
why I've had the backslash ends there
all the time but that's why they need to
be there to tell the computer to
actually put things where you want them
alternatively you know what okay I don't
like that ctrl C 4 cancel let me put
this one back what happens if I get rid
of this one and let me go ahead and
recompile the code first as you note dot
slash hello enter ok I've cleaned up
that missed that aesthetic headache
enter ok I mean it's not quite the same
problem but this looks stupid too
because the dollar sign just represents
my prompt where I'm supposed to type
commands and yet hello comma David
prompt this is messy so this is why
we've had all of these new lines now you
asked earlier what if you put the
newline elsewhere in the string well
suppose I do that suppose I put a couple
of them let me do this and noting no
spaces whatsoever now this is looking a
little weird but the computer is just
going to interpret this literally print
h-e-l-l-o comma newline substitute in
the string for % s then another new line
so how many lines of output is this
gonna display I heard four
other values let's see let's go ahead
and make hello and then run dot slash
hello what is your name as before enter
hello comma newline
David so four total lines certainly or
just two lines from the computer itself
so just to recap then with code like
this how many functions have I used in
this particular program
how many functions so it's two printf
which we've been using and getstring
which is the new one
where is getstring declared cs50 dot H
printf bean while is declared in
standard i/o dot H standard input/output
meanwhile string this data type also
comes from cs50 itself and then we've
used the format codes and we've used
variables to achieve the same result and
let's just hammer this home Kundera
Brian and cream do you mind popping up
for just a second or who's a Erin come
on up so just to make this clear because
there's now some terminology that we
want to use let's see do you want to be
you'll be getstring okay so we have some
name tags here like you get it
events so air in shall be get underscore
string if you want to go ahead and put
this this on okay and Brian you want to
be print F so we won't act out all of
our actual programs because this will
quickly become obvious so Brian is
printf so this point though remains in
that like this is nice that I have some
colleagues with whom I work here because
I don't really want to do all of the
hard work of like making things happen
and so if I'm instead the programmer
we're sort of the orchestrator of a
whole bunch of things happening I can
actually sort of implement this code now
more physically and let's focus though
for just a moment on what the sort of
key takeaways are one functions can take
inputs those inputs are called arguments
or parameters and functions can return
things they can have return values
printf for instance does it take inputs
what's the input to printf for instance
yeah like hello world whatever it is you
want to print is by definition the input
to printf does printf return a value
thus far it does do something on the
screen certainly like a print stuff on
the screen but we haven't seen it return
something because we haven't seen it
with an equal sign to the left now it
turns out printf does return things it's
just not often that useful to use but
we've only seen printf for the moment is
taking inputs more on that another time
getstring meanwhile does getstring take
inputs how many inputs just one the
prompt that you want the human to see
the first prompt I used was what is your
name
I could put make the prompt anything but
that's the question that getstring is
asking does gets during return a value
it does that's of course in scratch
called answer hard-coded as answer we
can store it in any variable we want so
let me just go ahead and implement this
program Aaron go get me a string and ask
the person what is their name so so
she's writing down Elizabeth now but
Aaron has taken input from me Aaron go
get someone's name and ask them what is
their name and now you've produced
output for me thank you this is the
return value storing the value Elizabeth
and I'm gonna go ahead and tuck it away
in the variable called name like this
piece of paper here okay Brian could you
go ahead and say hello Elizabeth
okay so what's going on here I'm just
doing less work right like I kind of
been writing this program Aaron go get
someone's name Brian could you print
this out like that's what I've been
doing is programming just delegating
functionality to other functions or in
this case other humans who know how to
do that and honestly I don't know have
to know how Aaron got that name she just
got it I don't have to know how Brian
wrote in that particular kind of style
of English on the screen I just know
that he can do it and now my program is
complete thank you very much to both of
these two here we'll continue in just a
moment as follows so all this time we've
been taking for granted that we have an
actual computer on which we can execute
code and I keep saying Intel Inside cuz
that's the sort of silly slogan that you
see inside of most Macs and PCs with the
hardware they have but the CPU is just
the brains of the computer and at the
end of the day
recall that the goal is to actually have
the computer turn something like this
source code into actual machine code
zeros and ones and that's all claying
was actually doing for us of course
we've only just scratched the surface
now of what we can do it turns out
there's going to be not just these
commands that we can run but other
features of C and in particular the cs50
library we've only seen thus far how to
get a string but you can get integers
and characters and funky things like
floats and doubles which actually open a
can of worms as two problems that can
happen in the computer and it turns out
you can store different types of
variables not just integers and strings
but bool for boolean and chars for
characters and you can format those
things in printf we've only seen percent
I a percent s I alluded to percent i
earlier but there's a few other still
but we've got a lot of possibilities
here but let's go ahead and take say a
five-minute break to give everyone bit
of a respite turn on some music and come
back in five and dive in deeper to more
sophisticated programs in C all right so
recall we began by comparing some
scratch blocks against the corresponding
C code but we didn't actually use most
of those blocks in C just yet so let's
try out a number of examples some of
which I'll write on the fly in code
typing code out on my own keyboard some
of which we already have in the courses
website so we can just open them to save
some time but let me just draw your
attention to what CSV
sandbox is because this was the step
that I skipped over earlier cs50 sandbox
can be used to program in bunches of
languages will initially in the semester
use it for SI but if you've written PI
Java before or Python or any number of
languages when you go to sandbox about
cs50 IO
you can simply choose the language you
want to write in and then at the bottom
you'll see you can specify the name of
the file you want to pre create so for
instance what I did earlier was I
selected C at top and then at the bottom
I typed in hello dot C because that was
the name of the file I wanted and then I
clicked start and what that led me to
was precisely the interface in which we
wrote hello dot C just a moment ago
where my code editor appears on the top
here my terminal window appears at the
bottom and then I'm allowed to just
start writing code so that's how we got
to where we were and if you want to
follow along now with some of these
examples note that on the courses
website we have all of them pre-made and
you can actually click the links on this
on the courses website and open up your
own copy of a sandbox with that code so
if the Wi-Fi cooperates you're welcome
to tinker and play and run the same
commands but everything is also on the
courses website after so you need to
type everything out so let's go ahead
and do just a quick example I'm gonna
call this int dot C just so that we can
reinforce some of what we did just a
moment ago rather than get a string like
we did with our Hello example let me go
ahead and just get say an integer and
then print it out just as we did print a
name so I'm gonna have to go ahead and
just through muscle memory I kind of
remember that I need standard i/o dot H
at the top and then int main void and
then curly braces and then I can do the
act of actually getting the input so
there was a function before called
getstring turns out there's another
function called get int if you want to
get an integer so I can actually call
get int
and I can say something like integer is
the prompt like hey human please give me
an integer
I need a semicolon at the end of this
line and then how do I actually store
the return value of get int in a
variable just as Aaron handed me a sheet
of paper with a string how do if I'm
handed a sheet of paper with a number
how do I store it somewhere
what should I literally type on line 5
here int space and the number or
something so I'm gonna call it I just
because it's an entry
I could call it number or anything else
and then I'm gonna go ahead and print
this out so printf let's say something
like hello I backslash n semicolon okay
not quite correct right this is gonna
literally print hello comma I how do I
actually substitute something in well
we've only seen how to substitute in two
strings but I think I spoiled earlier
the answer fuse % i that says hey
computer put an integer here and then I
need a second argument to printf just as
we handed Brian an argument as well and
I said I I want to say I here but this
program isn't quite correct yet it's in
a file called in dot C I've included
standard IO dot H it's in main and so
what is made well today we're largely
gonna wave our hands at that but int
main void is perhaps the most cryptic
way you can say the equivalent of when
green flag clicked like that's all that
does and we'll come back in the weeks to
come as to why it's int why it's May and
why it's void but for now humans years
ago just decided that when you're
writing a program in C and you want to
start the program off you literally have
to type int main void with those
parentheses with those curly braces and
it's the equivalent to scratches when
green flag clicked but this program will
not compile and I don't even want to
induce the stress of like seeing those
errors how do I avoid it yeah I need to
teach the computer that get int exists
and I know how to do that from before by
including the so-called cs50 library
technically cs50 dot H is a header file
dot H means header and it's just a file
containing C code in which the functions
are created more on that another time
but that just gives us access to printf
so if I've made no typos I should be
able to compile this program by running
what command make int I could do clang I
could do clang - OH
but for now I'm gonna do it simpler
would just make int and let make
automate the process of compiling this
program no error messages is good let me
go ahead and zoom in dot slash int I
think would run the program integer how
about 42 hello 42 a notice I can save
time now if I want to run it again I
don't have to do dot slash into all the
time it turns out that in this kind of
Linux environment this operating system
called Linux you can actually go up and
down
and see previous commands you've typed
and some others that have to be sipping
to be system specific and if you just
hit up and enter you can run it again
type in 50 this time and see another
output as well alright so any questions
then on just an example like that no
well let me go ahead and I'm gonna save
time in this environment I can actually
create files in here if I want by
clicking the folder icon clicking the
plus and then I can actually say give me
a file called float dot save so this is
equivalent to going back to the main
menu and typing in the name of the file
I'm just gonna do it a little more
quickly now in this graphical
environment and I want to call it float
dot C it's a bit of a weird name because
at least going up you probably learned
maybe about integers you probably
learned about real numbers numbers that
can have decimal points and then things
after the decimal point in a computer
those things with decimal points are
called floating point values or floats
and you can think of it as the decimal
point can kind of float to the left or
the right depending on how big or small
the number is or how precise the numbers
after the decimal point are that's a
float so let me go ahead and implement a
very similar program include cs50.h
include standard IOH int main void and
this is after 20 years of doing this
that you can do it so quickly
now let me instead get a float from the
user so a real number that may very well
have a decimal point in it I'm gonna do
that a little differently I'll zoom in
and I'm gonna say hey computer give me a
float as is the data type called not int
not string but float I'll call it F just
because that sounds like float and it's
nice and succinct equals get float and
then I'm just gonna say float that's the
prompt I could make the prompt in green
anything I want and now I'm gonna print
it print F hello F but I don't want F I
want to actually print out a placeholder
and you can probably guess by now what
the pattern is percent F for a float
newline comma F semicolon so this is
like the same program three times now
with a string with an int and a float
but again just for some muscle memory
and going through the pattern but let's
see what happens differently here let me
go ahead and type make float enter ok
good no errors let me zoom in and run
this now as as dot slash flow
and let me go ahead and type in a number
I'm gonna just say 42 but the computer
now has the capability of storing more
precision before it was just an integer
by definition of int now it's a flow so
even though it's pretty precise is 42.0
oh that's indeed a real number now
storing some amount of precision there
so it turns out though that we can do
more interesting math let me go ahead
and just open this example in advance
this one's going to be called in stat
sees that I don't have to type
everything out and in in stats II we're
gonna see some math written in code that
I pre created just to reinforce that you
can actually do some basic arithmetic in
a program I can make see more of the
code here by just scrolling down and let
me scroll this up so we can focus on
main and let me zoom in on the first few
lines on this first line I'm just
getting an int and I'm calling it X
we've not used a variable called X
recently but now we are it's no
different logically than before here
give me another variable so we can see
now that you can get multiple variables
from the user just like in scratch and
now in these lines in green are just
some format strings just what do I want
printf to display I literally in this
highlighted line here want printf to
display X plus y equals something what
is that something will notice what's
cool about printf is that before it is
passed in input you can perform simple
arithmetic operation so if you want to
add x and y together literally do X plus
y then the sum of those numbers is
what's get will get handed to printf as
its input just like I handed Aaron's
piece of paper to Brian as input I'm
handing not X&Y to Brian in this case
but X plus y or some value the actual
sum similarly subtraction is the the -
on your keyboard for multiplication it's
not an X it would that would be weird
X X Y it's instead star or an asterisk
on your keyboard Division is a single
slash and then this one's a little
flunky but we'll come up with some uses
for this you can actually do modular
arithmetic or just more simply
remainders if you do X % Y you'll get
back the remainder of dividing X by Y
and what's the remainder so if the nut
if X is 20 and Y is
well 20/10 goes in twice perfectly so
remainder is zero for instance it's been
a while so notice that what's curious
here in this context percent is not a
placeholder it's not percent as it's not
percent i-it's not percent F notice it's
not inside a printf format string this
is just literally math a math operator
as is implied by the different color
blue there
so if actually run this let's go ahead
and run this program I'm gonna go ahead
and door and make int plural because
that's the name of the file enter dot
slash int and let me zoom in and clear
the screen enter give me a number two I
heard and another 10 not heard so FYI 10
a 2 plus 10 is 12 2 minus 10 is negative
8 2 times 10 is 20 2 divided by 10 to
mod y or 2 and then take the remainder
when dividing by Y is what mod means is
2 um so that I get like 4 out of 5 for
correctness what's a little funky here
yeah which was like 2/10 like I'm pretty
sure that's like 2/10 or maybe 1/5 or
point to I mean I'll take any number of
answers but not zero so what's going on
well this is a matter of representation
it turns out in a computer program we
decided in advance I'm gonna store imps
ok and into something that does not have
a decimal point and yet here I am rather
presumptuously trying to do to an
integer divided by 10 and integer and
expecting something other than integer
no like I literally am doing integer
arithmetic so what's the computer
apparently doing just intuitively why
when dividing X by Y as I did in this
line here or specifically in this
example you proposed 2/10 where is my
2/10 going yeah it's as though like it's
technically what's supposed to be point
2 or 0.2 ok that's actually this
solution right because if it's zero
point two but integers can't store
decimal points or anything after them
what do you have left just the zero at
the beginning so integer arithmetic is
fine if you're
with integers but if you want
floating-point arithmetic you're gonna
need to make some changes and so I can
fix this in fact let me go ahead and
write a different program here let me go
ahead and open up from the courses
website floats dot C and that's gonna
give me this example which is
implemented using floating point values
instead so once this loads I'm gonna see
a program I wrote in advance it's a
little shorter because now I only care
about looking at one problem and notice
now x and y are now floats and not int
another data type that exists and I'm
using get float which also comes from
cs50 s library and then this line is
almost the same but you know what let me
let me tweak this let me just make it
exactly the same this line now that I've
highlighted is exactly the same as
before
so if I do type in these same numbers so
let's go ahead and zoom in and do make
floats plural and dot slash floats
I'll give it two and ten and I should
hopefully see what now zero point two
yeah okay that's pretty good pretty
precise but you know what I hate to tell
you but let's look a little farther it
turns out by default when you do percent
F you only see a few decimal places like
five or so it looks by default let me
see a bit a few more so this was one
this was one two three four five six
points after the decimal point so you
know what I'm gonna say hey computer
give me seven decimal points this looks
completely cryptic and you just have to
kind of remember this or look it up if
you forget if you put a dot and a number
in between the percent and the F that's
the cryptic way of telling the computer
show me a float but with this many
decimal places please so that just gives
me seven decimal places weird as the
expression looks alright hopefully I'm
just gonna see some more zeroes so let
me go ahead and make floats and let me
go ahead and zoom in and do dot slash
floats to ten enter okay still correct
let me get a little curious let's see a
lot of zeros like 50 of them let me go
down here and do make floats because I
change the code dot slash floats to ten
hah your grade school teachers lied to
you
2/10 is apparently not point two zero
zero zero zero zero zero infinitely it's
apparently a point two zero zero zero
zero zero zero zero two nine eight zero
two three two two three eight seven six
nine five three one two five and then
all of those zeros what the hell is
going on where's the bug where's my
mistake where's my misunderstanding
what's the explanation for this well
what if I told you that inside of your
computer is stuff like this this is RAM
or memory and you've probably generally
known this idea right late to store
files to store music and videos like you
need memory some kind of space hard disk
space is permanent storage RAM or random
access memory is temporary storage so
when your bet your laptop is open or
your desktop computers on or your phone
is powered you're using Ram for all of
the programs you're running at once if
you open a file that file is stored in
RAM but it's permanently stored on your
hard drive so there's different types of
memory but notice this is zoomed in in
reality this is like a couple of inches
wide and maybe an inch tall so it's
pretty small but it doesn't really
matter how big it is it just matters
that it's finite in size you have
physical Hardware on your laps or in
your pockets or at home that only are so
big and therefore only have so many
parts and therefore only have so many
transistors and other pieces of hardware
that's actually doing the work of
storing information and so if you only
have a finite amount of memory how in
the world are we going to represent an
infinite number of numbers because I do
recall from grade school I was taught
there's an infinite number of numbers
certainly real numbers where the decimal
point can go on forever that is a
problem if you want to represent all
possible numbers in the universe which
is infinitely many with a finite amount
of hardware so at some point the
computers got to start cutting some
corners and so what you're really seeing
here is as close as the computer can get
to storing that fraction for you
precisely and I got a little greedy I
looked a little too far to the right and
these are infinitely small like values
it's not hugely hugely off but it is off
because I can't expect the computer to
end represent an infinite number of
values using a finite amount of memory
it's got a kind of round off here or
there and be imprecise so to speak so is
this a problem I mean I we would never
have known this if I hadn't gotten
greedy and looked at 50 decimal places
instead of seven which was already
pretty precise is this a problem yeah
like why why yeah that's a good one
logically if I start using equals equals
to compare things for equality I'm gonna
be it's gonna be really hard for me to
ever compare something for 2/10 as its
value because I'm gonna literally have
to like remember or write down or figure
out this value and compare against that
and not just compare more loosely
against point two and that's true you
should actually never compare floating
point values in code for equality I
could probably get away with less than
or greater than but even then it's gonna
be a little off from what I expect why
else might this imprecision be worrisome
when might you not want your computer
being imprecise what domains what worlds
outside of a classroom yeah what's that
yeah so Rockets right there anything
involving math and physics and and
danger like you don't want numbers to be
ever so slightly off and if you think
about it Rockets is a good example
because I don't know much about Rockets
but I know they go pretty fast and
there's probably like angles involved
because you're trying to keep them on a
trajectory and that's fine but if your
trajectory is ever so slightly off and
something is going really fast and
really far you know I'm pretty sure that
like eventually those small imprecisions
start to add up and indeed there's been
historical instance that incidents where
that kind of imprecision does in fact
add up in the realm of militaristic
operations or in financial operations in
fact if you've ever seen office space or
way back when like Superman 3 like this
is how some people made some money
because they just kind of kept all of
the fractions of pennies that computer
systems we're just ignoring and
eventually they start to add up so long
story short
anytime you have scientific or financial
or any sort of large data sets that
involve big numbers and lots of them in
lots of time this is a problem and it
almost suggests you shouldn't you see
her let alone computers unless we
actually address this now as a spoiler
humans have chipped away at this problem
and you can use more and more bits but
not infinitely many bits at some point
you have to draw a line but this is why
for instance the stock exchange might
only represent two decimal points of
precision for dollars or maybe for
decimal points to the thousands place
for dollars and cents and they just have
to decide that's all the precision we
can actually store precisely but you've
got to decide how to handle it and not
just ignore the problem but we can do a
little better you know what it turns out
that in most computers afloat
it takes up yes a finite amount of space
but very specifically 32 bits of space
or 4 bytes a byte recall is 8 bits so 4
bytes is 32 bits and that's just a very
common unit of measure but there's
another one turns out if you want twice
as many bits you can literally use a
data type called double and in the cs50
library there are functions called there
is a function called get double and if I
go ahead and do it here I can now
recompile this code make floats even
though they're not technically float
types anymore and let me go ahead and do
dot slash floats ENTER and let me type
in 2 and 10 and now it's still imprecise
but notice instead of seven zeros which
I think I had before now I've got 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 zeros so
I've kind of pushed the problem further
out so to speak so it's more precise but
it's not perfect
can't get certain values perfect if you
want to be able to represent an infinite
range any questions then about this
we'll come back as to some implications
yeah yeah
good question it would always be better
to use doubles because they're more
precise short answer yes but we're gonna
see thematically in this course in
computer science more generally there's
always a trade-off and yes if you use a
double you will avoid this problem a bit
more but what price will you pay so to
speak
maybe processing power because it's got
to like deal with more bits at once and
even more literally more space I mean
sure we can take your solution but I'm
gonna charge you twice as many bits and
back-in-the-day decades ago when C was
first being invented and computers were
really coming into play spending twice
as many bits even if it's only 32 more
tiny zeros and ones that was actually
expensive literally financially and it
adds up and even today if you want to
spend more space that's fine but you're
gonna spend more space therefore more
money and therefore have less space
available for other things so it's just
a trade-off and you have to decide
decide is an intelligent human where the
right inflection point is between what's
more important let me open up a very
different example now called parity just
as an example and let me ask this
question how do you know if a number is
even or odd what's the trick if it's
divided by 2 so 0 & 2 & 4 & 6 are even
because if you divide by 2 you don't get
a remainder so actually if you just want
to see a quick example of why you might
use a remainder even though it's out of
context here's an example for parity
parity is just a term referring to even
or odd in this context how might we use
this well notice I can get an in from
the user up at the top I can then check
the parity of the integer is it even or
odd with syntax like this now I'm kind
of combining some of these operators as
you might be inclined intuitively if n
the number of the user typed in mod 2 or
/ and then check the remainder of but
that's a mouthful equals equals 0 you
just said it's an even number so print
even else print odd because what's the
possible other remainder if you do n or
any value divided by 2 you might get a
remainder of 0 or 1 I only have to check
for one of those 0 because the else
implies the other thing so again very
simple example but honestly all of us
probably have an intuitive understanding
of what's even an odd a computer needs
to be taught that and so there's a
program
does exactly that let me open up a
larger program called conditions and
rather than type this one out because
it's a few lines of code let me just
open it up because it concludes exactly
the code we saw a little bit of go on
the slide when we compared it to a
similar C Block in this program in my
main function let me focus on the first
few lines there I have an int called X
that I'm getting via get int another int
called Y then I'm getting via get int
and then I'm just doing some simple
comparisons we saw this again when we
compared to the scratch but this is
quite simply that same code in context
rather than just seeing it statically on
a slide so let me go ahead and compile
this make conditions enter seems to
compile let me zoom in and do dot slash
conditions enter X will be say 2 again Y
will be 10 X is indeed less than Y if I
run it again and I can save time by
hitting up through my history and just
hitting Enter let's do 2 & 2 and indeed
X is equal to Y and so forth so again
just the exact same kind of code as
before but now in the context of a
working program what if I actually
wanted to get user input kind of like
our past student did with getting yes or
no answers to the Apple and the cupcake
question well an answer dot C it turns
out you can actually get textual input
from the user
perhaps a simple yes-or-no or just Y or
n for succinct Ness and in this case if
I just get back a single character turns
out there's a separate datatype for
character if you don't want a whole
string like a whole word or a paragraph
or sentence or whatever you just want
one character you can actually use
what's called a char or character and so
here I'm using one other function
appropriately named called get char I'm
storing it in a variable called C
because it's nice and succinct of type
char and then notice this you might not
have seen this syntax before especially
if you've never programmed before even
in scratch but you might have seen this
block similar to this in scratch what is
the vertical double bar probably imply
here or that's it so in scratch it's
nice and user friendly they literally
just say oh are in programming it's
often the case that you use just more
cryptic sequences of characters and two
vertical bars which are like typically
above the
turkey on a u.s. keyboard if c equals
equals capital y or c equals equals
lowercase Y let's assume that the user
wanted to say yes and go ahead and say
yes else if the user typed in N in
capitals or in in lowercase let's assume
he or she meant no and say no
accordingly and what are we gonna do
otherwise apparently nothing and that's
fine you don't need to have a default
case if you want the program to do
nothing might be a little confusing
because the users gonna type in you know
some random word and get no output but
that's a design decision logically this
is just how we might express this what
about um what about actually building
our own blocks any questions though
before we start to create No all right
so recall that in scratch we had that
coughing Sam 'pl let me go ahead and
create a file here real quickly called
cough
zero dot C and just kind of recreate
what we did last week include standard
IOH int main void again just muscle
memory now and then printf quote unquote
cough backslash n semicolon and you know
what let me go ahead and call for not
once but twice three times like the
moment you start copying and pasting
you're probably not writing good code
right it's not very maintainable now if
I want to change the word or translate
it to another language I have to change
it in three places we already decided
last week that was bad so what would be
better in C or in scratch or in general
than this approach yeah so like a for
loop so let me do that let me create
another file I'm gonna call this one
coughed one dot C is my second version
let me go ahead now and just copy and
paste the original code and let's just
improve it let's get rid of two of these
and let's see if we can't express the
four so it was four let me zoom in int I
gets 0 I is less than some number before
it was 50 now I'm gonna have it be 3 I
plus plus curly braces and now let me
move the coughed lock inside of there
and indent it just to be pretty and
notice stylistically I've been doing
this sort of instinctively for some time
everything is nicely indented just to
make it more readable quite like the
scratch box even though it
and a lot of that whitespace doesn't
matter to the computer so if I go ahead
and run this let me pull up the terminal
window so I can see it make
Koff one enter looks good dot slash
cough one cough cough cough okay that's
good but recall that we actually improve
this design further by abstracting it
away let me go ahead and make my own
function now let me go ahead and open up
a new file
Koff - coughs - dot C just like I had
another scratch program again include
standard IO dot H int main void and then
in here let me go ahead and do what well
for int I gets 0 I less than 3 I plus
plus plus curly braces then let me go
ahead and just call cough it would be
nice if coughing xizt 'add but
unfortunately coughed does not exist
it's not in the cs50 library even so
that's not gonna help us I have to make
my own function so in scratch you went
to the blocks thing and you make your
own block and the big prompt comes up
and you make your new puzzle piece here
we're gonna have to be a little more
deliberate and it turns out you can do
it like this some of these details will
be non obvious at first but I'm gonna go
ahead and call the function coffee and
coffee at the moment does not need to
take any input so the key word there is
void and we've actually seen that before
main also has not been taking any inputs
that's why we had the word void but more
on that another time and coffee is not
gonna return anything either it's gonna
print on the screen just like Brian did
but Brian recall didn't hand me anything
back physically so there's no return
value so I'm gonna say void to the left
of cob so for today's purposes this just
means that coffee neither takes input
nor returns a value as output that's it
void void now as the body of that
function so to speak I'm just gonna go
ahead and say quite simply Koff
backslash n semicolon that's it so now I
have a puzzle piece if you will whose
purpose in life is to cough which means
now I can magically just call it by its
name up here as many times as I want so
let's go ahead and compile this I'm
really on a good roll everything's been
working out great so far make coughed to
enter
Oh red errors so this is interesting and
this kind of reminds me of the previous
error so first of all what line is my
error on okay seven and character nine
if you care but it's seven on line seven
implicit declaration of function coffee
is invalid in c99 c99 is referring to
literally 1999 when this version of C
was invented and so implicit declaration
of function coughed but it's right here
uh okay wait a minute let me I instinct
let me just move this right if let me
just put it up top let's see what
happens
make coughed - oh my god that fixed it
why like even if you've never programmed
before just kind of Reason through
intuitively why this solves something
exactly
exactly because I previously was trying
to use cough early on on line seven but
I was only teaching the computer what
COFF was farther down in the file
frankly C is kind of dumb it literally
reads your code top to bottom left to
right and if you try to do something
before you've taught the computer how to
do that you're gonna get that kind of
undeclared identifier because it just
doesn't know what the word is yet now in
scratch this isn't a big deal you just
move the puzzle pieces anywhere you want
order of blocks physically on the screen
does not matter but in C it does but
frankly this seems a little annoying
that now the main program here kind of
keeps getting pushed farther and farther
down the more kind of complexity I want
to add to my program so there's another
solution let me actually go ahead and
put this back where it is because I'm a
little sort of particular I just like by
convention main to be at the top and
frankly that's kind of good style if
main is the most important function in
your program by default because it is
the main program a function and it's
what gets called per earlier by default
by the computer why am I gonna push it
all the way down just to work around
this stupid detail well I just need to
teach the computer what the function is
and I can do that a little redundantly
by just saying this this is what we're
going to call the prototype for a
function
if you literally just copy the very
first line of it that has its name its
inputs if any and its output if any
that's a prototype semicolon it's
literally copy-paste from the function
itself but this is now enough of a hint
to say hey computer this shell exists
this is enough information for you to
then call it because the computer speaks
so long as it is seen the functions name
before it's okay if the zeros and ones
so to speak that implement it come a
little later and so that's the more
conventional way to solve that problem
so just intuitively then take a guess if
it's not too much of a indirect leap
what is in standard i/o dot H what is in
cs50 dot H those kinds of dick we'll
call them declarations so literally in
standard i/o dot H is a line of code
that teaches the computer what printf
inputs are and what printf s-- output is
if any in cs50 dot H there's literally a
nine of code that tells the computer
what get strings input is and what its
output is and the same forget int and
get float and get char and others that's
all that's in those header files the
zeros in one so to speak are actually in
files literally called standard i/o dot
C and cs50 dot C although that's
technically source code the zeros and
ones are in a compiled file elsewhere on
the system but all of these things we've
kind of been taking for granted now
hopefully it makes a little more sense
because the fact that I'm doing a sharp
include at the top that's just a
solution to a problem in that file is
enough information to teach the computer
what printf or what getstring and other
things are so that I don't need to
bother moving things around myself or
copying and pasting whoever wrote printf
his or her code into my program now
let's do one final example with coughing
and go ahead and call this coffee three
dot C and go ahead and paste my same
code as a moment ago just to get us
started and recall that the last step of
our coffee example last week was to
actually give coffin input I'd kind of
like to whittle this code down to
literally COFF 3 because this is a
really nice abstraction like I don't
want Maine to have to think about how
many times to just call three times
that's an
nice useful human abstraction now let's
put the functionality down here so if I
want COFF to be able to tolerate an
input like 3 which mentions a void
presumably needs to change the one on
the left or the right the right the one
inside the parenthesis and it turns out
just like you can declare variables
inside of a function as we've done so
can you declare arguments to a function
like this so you can call it anything
you want though the datatype matters but
this is now saying hey computer
Koff does not return a value like Aaron
did return a piece of paper hey computer
coffee does take one input it's an
integer and just call it n and now that
you've done this now you can have a line
of code in here like this for int I gets
0 I is less than n I plus plus plus plus
plus and then okay off by keystrokes
here then I can move this inside here
indent it nicely and now notice all of
the complexity of coughing has been
factored out into a function my own
puzzle piece if you will that even takes
an argument so that now you can
literally if I move this far away and
out of mind now your programs getting
pretty interesting because it really
just does what it says and this is a
nice functional abstraction if you will
so that now I have a new verb a new
action a new function called cough any
questions on that one yeah
sorry take in what integer would main
return it turns out it will come back to
this it's going to return 0 almost
always by default but that leaves you
with almost an infinite number of
nonzero values which represent all of
the many things that can go wrong so
more on that when we start creating more
mistakes let's look at one other let me
go ahead and open this file in advance
myself called positive dot C suppose
that I'm not content to just have access
to get int I want a function called get
positive int because for whatever reason
my program my game I whatever needs to
know a positive value maybe I'm asking
the user how many players are there and
that shouldn't be negative it should be
a positive integer like 1 or 2 or more
so it turns out I could write a program
if I want that looks like this
call on this line here a function called
get positive int pass it in a prompt and
then store the value still in an integer
on the left hand side and then just go
ahead and print it out get positive int
has this prototype at the top of the
file notice this is not a function that
comes with cs50 library cs50.h the
function is called get positive int as
you would hope it returns an int and it
takes a string as its prompt whatever
words you want the human to see let's
scroll down now and this one's looks a
little more involved and this is not a
feature that scratch has but let's take
a look the first line is identical to
the prong to the prototype because I
literally copied and pasted it
everything between these brackets is the
function itself and here to answer
someone's question from earlier on do
you have to declare a variable and then
use it right away no and that's actually
a helpful solution to a problem that
we'll see in a moment notice here this
new keyword didn't see it before do the
following while n is less than one
previously we saw a while loop and we
saw a for loop we did not see a do-while
loop and a do-while loop well it sounds
obviously similar to a while loop what
seems a little different when I had that
forever block earlier translated to
while true what was the order of
operations did we check the condition
the true and then print hello world or
did we just print hello world and then
check the condition yeah you might not
recall precisely but I did actually I
checked is true true and we all said yes
obviously printf is it true printf is it
true printf so wait check the condition
first you might infer then this loop is
a little different it has another word
do this is literally going to do this
first and then check the condition and
only do it again if the condition is
true so it's a nice way of just flipping
things around in terms of order to do
something at least once rather than
potentially never at all like was the
case earlier so what are we doing get an
int passing in this prompt stored in N
and if the user types in a value that's
less than 1 is this going to be true or
false if n is less than 1
so if n is like if the human types in
zero is zero less than one true yes so
what happens you go back to the do and
you do it again if the user types a
negative 1 is negative 1 less than 1 yes
or true so you do it again if he or she
types in negative 2 again again what if
he or she types in 50 well 50 is not
less than 1 so this is false and so then
you proceed to the next line of code
altogether but what's interesting about
the next line of code is that unlike the
COFF example which had void as its
return type get positive int by default
is supposed to return an INT just like
again Aran handed me a piece of paper
with a string on it and so here if I
want my own custom function called get
positive into return a value there's
another word in C you literally write
return and then the name of the variable
or the value that you want to hand back
on a metaphorical piece of paper to
whatever code is using this so what's
this oddity why can I not do this if I
were to mimic the code we wrote earlier
like this why does this line of code not
work just logically using some of the
sort of mental model that we've had thus
far Segan yeah so declaring just means
creating is the fancy way in programming
of saying creating so this says hey
computer give me an integer call it n
and set it equal to the return value of
get in so whatever the function or aaron
hands me back put it over here but the
problem is that in c variables have
scope scope is a fancy way of saying
they only exist in between the curly
braces between which they were declared
so that means that this line this
variable n literally only exists between
here and here and then it just kind of
goes away the computer doesn't know
about it anymore but that's a problem
because on what line number do we
actually need to know n looks like 21
and that's outside the curly braces so
just based on that basic definition
scope is the two curly braces between
which a variables declared it doesn't
exist outside of them this code just
won't work and I'll fix it later so that
you see the correct error message why
does this not
work well you're declaring in inside of
those curly braces so how do you avoid
this well it turns out is someone
posited earlier just to clear it by
itself without even giving it a value
and indeed the syntax for that is just
to do half of a thought in ten semicolon
it has no value that we know yet it has
a garbage value but more on that another
time but it does now exist and now
notice which curly braces does it exist
within this one and this one which means
now it's accessible everywhere and if
you and your scratch programs actually
used variables you might have noticed
that you had to choose you had to make a
decision for this sprite or for all
sprites that was an allusion to what's
called in programming a local or a
global variable these are still local
and we'll come back to this term earlier
but it has to do with scope because if
you had specified for this sprite only
MIT would have only let you use that
variable for that specific sprite that
cat or or sheep or whatever it was you
were programming just as in C this now
means n can be used here in here but not
elsewhere like higher up in my program
that's the matter of scope so let's now
see what can go wrong beyond that let me
go ahead and open up this because it
turns out when programming there's other
issues that can happen not just floating
point imprecision as I described it as
earlier it turns out that there's other
problems that can go wrong even with
integers that we kind of avoided
altogether so recall that we started
talking about one two and three and why
it's 123 last week well what happens in
decimal if you add 101 to 123 what
number do you get obviously 124 if we do
it again 100 25 26 27 28 29 what happens
in decimal if I add 1 to a 9 well I
should get 10 but that's not how we
would write this right you put down the
0 instead and you carry the 1 right
remember those kind of sort of mental
heuristics so that's all we did there
and then it's 2 plus 1 so that's why 129
plus 1 is 130 because you put the 0 you
carry the 1 and so forth so we just all
do that intuitively now but this has
implications for what computers do too
because suppose that we consider a
bigger number like 999
and so what do you get when you add 1 to
999 well you carry the one you carry the
one and you get hopefully a thousand but
what if your computer only has space for
three digits or what if your phone or
what if your alarm clock or whatever the
device is literally only has room for
three digits
what is 999 plus 1 if your hardware only
has 3 digits
well it's apparently zero so you get
this kind of overflow where 1 not 998
999 0 it overflows so to speak the one
kind of falls off conceptually and you
roll over to the next value which is 0 0
0 so what about in binary what number is
this in binary if you translate it to
decimal in your head and remember it's
the ones column the twos column and the
fours column so this was 7 in binary 1
so it's 4 plus 2 plus 1 so 7 in binary
so how do you do arithmetic with binary
it's actually the same thing it's just
you don't have to Zoar threes or nines
or anything in between
you just have ones and zeros so what do
you get when you add 1 2 1 1 1 well it's
the same idea you put down a 0 and you
carry the 1 because 1 plus 1 you want to
say 2 in decimal but there is no 2 so it
rolls over to 0 but you carry the 1 1
plus 1 is 2 but ok that's 0 carry the 1
1 plus 1 that's 2 but I don't have a 2
so I go back to 0
carry the 1 so in binary if you only
have 3 bytes or bits rather if you only
have 3 bits what do you get when you add
1 to 7 in binary you apparently get 0
and now it's getting more real right in
my computer in my phone in all of your
hardware it's just a finite amount of
memory RAM that little chip that I
showed on the screen with all the little
circuits and that has more than 3 bits
of memory certainly but it is finite and
if we're only using as matter of
convention 32 bits to represent things
or 64 bits maybe if we use doubles or
something else called along along is a
64-bit integer whereas an integer is
typically 32 bits it seems that at some
point numbers might overflow and we're
gonna actually have some so to speak
imprecision ergo integer overflow so you
can actually see this or
defenses against this in the real world
so this is a screenshot from a game that
is common on a few different platforms
and it's a game that allows you to
accumulate coins or points really or
little LEGO pieces and if you accumulate
these points you'll notice that
eventually if you have way too much free
time you can only score so high in this
game what's the highest score apparently
according to the screenshot from whoever
took this after playing for too many
hours wasn't me
four million no four billion four
billion why is that well it turns out
that if numbers and computers as I've
proposed are generally stored using 32
bits that kind of invites the question
well how high can you count with 32 bits
well 32 bits means you have 32 zeros and
ones the biggest they could have be is
like one one one one one 32 ones and if
you actually do the math using our
little columns and so forth it's roughly
four billion a little bigger than four
billion so the authors of this Lego game
just decided you know what let's just
say that the maximum number of points or
coins you can accumulate in this Lego
game is 4 billion even why it just looks
even cleaner than whatever the actual
value is but why how many bits are they
using to store your score in this game
presumably 32 bits or 4 bytes and that's
just convention whatever language they
program this game is probably has a
datatype called an int and that int by
convention uses 32 bits so at some point
they to decide we can either use more
memory as you proposed earlier for
doubles let's use 64 bits then you can
have crazy numbers of hours playing the
game and getting more and more points or
we can just say that's enough points to
accumulate in the game now that's when
you actually anticipate this this
doesn't always actually happen if we go
ahead and take a look at in some example
code let me go ahead and open up
overflow dot C in this program here
you'll see on line 8 this slash slash
syntax and I've had a bunch of these so
far but I haven't actually mentioned
them turns out in see just like in
scratch though odds are you didn't
notice this little feature of scratch
you can never bear called comments a
comment is just a word a note to
yourself to your TF to your friend to
your colleague with over whom you're
writing code with and it's just a note
to self like to remind yourself of what
the code does right without this line I
once I'm comfortable enough programming
kind of figure out what these lines of
code are doing but frankly that's a
waste of time I wrote the code once and
if I look at it weeks or months later or
someone else wrote it just tell me what
it does so a comment in a program it's
just like a nice summary of like a few
lines of code or it's a summary in
English or whatever spoken language that
kind of describes what otherwise a
cryptic looking code might actually be
doing so you don't have to think too
hard about it to understand a program so
iteratively double-eye iteratively it
just means looping li again and again
and again this is funky we didn't see
this before but you might guess what it
does what the star equals do it does
double it's like plus equals adds one
star equals doubles if the value on the
right is 2 so this is going to start
printing 1 then 2 then 4 then 8 and and
so forth and notice this function it's
called sleep it literally is gonna sleep
for a second and that sleep function has
a prototype that someone else wrote and
a file called uni standard dot h io know
that by looking it up in the
documentation but that's a new file just
for sleeping make overflow which is kind
of apt here and let me go ahead and make
the terminal window even bigger for this
one dot slash overflow okay
it's going it's going it's gonna go
faster and faster so to speak because
we're adding more and more each time by
doubling all right two thousand four
thousand eight thousand sixteen thousand
it's still going 64 65,000 now we're
into the millions - millions four eight
sixteen million it's getting bigger and
bigger all of these big numbers ooh
interesting
what just happened like so it turns out
if you double number is big enough you
get zero eventually also something you
probably weren't taught so what actually
happened ctrl C will cancel this what
happened I mean the program's trying to
tell me even though it's a little
cryptic signed integer overflow sign
just means it went from positive to
negative essentially so what happened
what's that yeah I ran out of bits I'm
doubling the number again and again and
again and at some point we carried the
ones
so to speak and it was a 33rd one
therefore passed the boundaries of a
32-bit value and it just rolled over to
apparently a negative because at some
point we haven't talked about it you can
use like the leftmost bit in some sense
to say positive or negative we've just
talked about positive so far and then at
that point frankly the computer just
gave up not really knowing what you
intended beyond that so if you don't
write code to handle this situation and
make sure that your numbers are less
than 4-billion before you roll over just
bugs will happen and this might seem
contrived here but this happens not too
long ago so 1999 was just before a lot
of people thought the world was gonna
end because of the so-called y2k bug and
it really wasn't so much a bug as it was
like lack of forethought or lack of
features what was the y2k problem in a
nutshell someone want to propose even in
a non-technical sense yeah yeah yeah so
they didn't so let me summarize here so
if they are only using two digits to
display values you could confuse the
year 2000 with actually the year 1900
because long story short what humans did
kind of reasonably decades ago was you
know space was expensive computers were
expensive memory was not sort of as
abundant as it is now with all the cloud
storage and the like so you know what if
it was like 1970 do we really care about
1969 1968 let alone 1900 not really
let's just assume we're all in the 1900s
and never show or store 1/9 let's just
store two digits for every year so 7 0
is 70 99 is 1999 but the problem is the
humans ended up running code that they
wrote years ago decades ago way longer
than humans thought they might why well
it's expensive its time consuming to
change code the codes working why try to
break it problem is - as people aged and
and passed away there's fewer and fewer
people that even knew the languages in
which those programs were written and so
now who's going to even update the
software so like lots of problems were
or were feared and this really just
boils down to because 1999 might have
overflowed - not 0 per se but in
implicit 1900
and indeed this definitely happened
though not nearly on the scale as people
fought but it does happen in even more
real terms just a few years ago this is
a Boeing 787 an actual airplane that had
to be grounded for some amount of time
because it had a programming error and
it summarized here in an online article
a 787 airplane that has been powered
continuously for 248 days it turns out
was the warning can lose all of its
electrical power due to the generator
going into failsafe mode why is that
this condition is caused by a software
counter internal to the generator that
will overflow after 248 days of
continuous power so translate that that
just means there's software running in
the Boeing's actual 787's they were
using 32-bit integers they were using
those integers to store hundreds of
seconds and at some point if you leave
your plane on for 248 days each of which
has 24 hours 60 minutes in an hour 60
seconds in a minute
and 100 tenths of a second or 101
hundreds of a second in every second
that product of multiplying things out
gets big pretty fast and on day two
hundred and forty nine planes
theoretically would shut down even in
the middle of flight for very real
reasons because a really big number
rolls over to zero and that confused the
generator these are actual smart you
know airplane engineers making these
kinds of mistakes because of software
not anticipating one line of code or
some number of lines of code or as you
propose why don't they just use more
bits and again these are very real
concerns so this was thankfully
addressed and solved but not before of
course there was quite the scare there
so it turns out in an older game this
was the game of civilization turns out
that one of the characters assumed you
can play Gandhi is actually not as
peaceful a character in the game is as
you might think and let's for context
just take a look here for a second if we
actually take a look at
some more binary this in binary is what
number in decimal okay one and this is
8-bit so it's a full byte eight bits is
a byte one two three four five six seven
eight so what do you get if you do one -
well if you subtract one from this you
obviously get what okay all 0 so 1 minus
1 is just 0 what if you get what if you
subtract 2 from this value what happens
it's this is actually called integer
underflow which is just the opposite but
there's really not too many options to
think about this if you only have zeros
and ones you can probably imagine what
the bad scenario is if 0 0 0 0 0 1 if
you subtract 1 goes to 0 and then you do
it again you now underflow which just
brings you around to the opposite 1 1 1
1 1 1 1 so if you have eight 1s what
value is that if you do the math ones
twos fours 8 16 it turns out it's 255 if
you actually do out all the math so it
turns out that this game civilization
was using a single byte to represent
every characters level of aggressiveness
in the game and gandhi's was as you
would expect by default initialized to 1
like very non aggressive unfortunately
in this game of civilization
when a player adopts democracy in his or
her civilization their aggression would
be automatically reduced by 2 and so if
Gandhi went Democratic his aggression
wouldn't go to negative 1 it looked back
around to the ludicrously high figure of
255 making him as aggressive as a
civilization could possibly be so less
impactful to be sure than something like
the airplane example but these problems
are omnipresent and if you start to keep
an eye out in the popular media or when
there are bugs or hacks or exploits it's
so often because programming in a
programmer has made a mistake in his or
her code they didn't anticipate a
scenario or they made maybe reasonable
decisions years ago but that eventually
proved to be naive and that we're still
running the same code numbers you're
getting too big their error of their
math is wrong and so very real things
happen but what's most important for us
is just understanding how and why those
things happen and so what will we do in
the days ahead so the next homework is
and as with scratch will be to program
something but this time in C you'll use
an environment called cs50 lab which
essentially is cs50 sandbox with which
we've been tinkering today but it adds
to it the instructions and the
specification of the problems that
you'll want to solve and it will hold
your hands initially through some of
these steps you don't need to have
written everything down and memorized
everything I typed today but do feel
free in the mean time to go to the
courses website and play with any of
those examples among the challenges
ahead will be to recreate some snippets
of games from yesteryear thinking about
how things you might have seen growing
up can be translated to actual code and
undoubtedly among the first things
you'll experience is frustration you'll
forget the stupid semicolon or where
does the parentheses go and you'll have
to look back at code but keep in mind
none of that stuff matters it's
absolutely frustrating initially but
what's most important is the ideas and
honestly the sense of gratification that
you like all of cs50 staff before you
ultimately feel when actually building
and creating something of your own let's
call it a day there and we'll see you
next time